Children struggling every day with ADHD.
Scott's allergies made it hard to keep up with his friends.
allergic reactions from accidental food exposures.
moderate to severe eczema.
black psoriasis, rheumatoid arthritis,
food allergies, allergy, seizure.
Health of American children is in crisis.
More than 40% of American children now have at least one chronic health condition.
autoimmune disease like rheumatoid arthritis,
human diabetes, lupus, Crohn's disease, all this IBS.
Just a few decades ago, one in 10,000 children had autism.
Today it's one in 31.
ADD, ADHD, Speechal Eyeway,
visually, text or adcentrum, narcolexies, sleep disorders.
There's no way in the world these kind of rapid increases in the incidence of disease
could be genetic. Genetic change takes generation centuries to play out.
What the heck is happening?
What is happening?
Chronic disease has gone from 12.8% in our children in the 1980s
to over 54% of our kids now.
That's the greatest decline in human health that's ever been recorded.
And people will say, how do you know it's not the pesticides sprayed all over our crops
or the hormones in our beef or plastics or forever chemicals.
But when we're talking about an autoimmune disease crisis,
which is what's happening in America,
should we look closest at the one product that's designed to alter our immune system
for life. And we don't just inject it one time or two times or 10 times or 15 times
or 20 times or 50 times, 72 times.
We are altering the immune system for our children with our vaccine program.
There'll be one easy study to rule it out,
compare vaccinated children to completely unvaccinated children.
But we don't know because they've never done the study.
The CDC's responsibility to do those studies,
and they've been worried again and again and again to do them, and they have refused.
This is information that vaccine safety advocates want,
and I'm not sure why it hasn't been done.
What we would need is a scientist that the CDC could trust.
They would have to be a passionately pro-vaccine, highly accredited group of scientists
willing to do a super robust retrospective,
vaccinated versus unvaccinated comparative study.
As fate would have it, Del Matt, the head of infectious disease at Henry Ford Health System,
Marcus Hervos. Dr. Hervos is the perfect epidemiologist for the study.
He's incredibly pro-vaccine, and he's also used to being in high-profile cases
because he was at the center of the Flint, Michigan water investigation.
Dr. Hervos only agreed to do this study to prove us wrong.
Del and I both that was an excellent opportunity.
We only had one request, whatever the outcome you publish it.
He said, whatever the results, they get published.
Would he stick to that?
Promise if the results show that unvaccinated kids are healthier?
Did it know?
Impact of childhood vaccination on short and long-term chronic health outcomes in children,
a birth cohort study. I've never seen this study before.
18,468 subjects.
Henry Ford, like other institutions, has a bias towards the goodness of vaccines.
If the results came back, demonstrating that the battery of vaccines was associated with chronic
diseases, such a result would be particularly convincing. This could be essentially one of the
most valuable studies in the field.
The vaccinated subjects were over four times more likely to have an asthma diagnosis.
600% more acute and chronic ear infections.
4.47 times the amount of speech disorders in the vaccinated compared to the unvaccinated.
Five and a half times risk.
616% increase.
Learning issues, developmental delays, speech delays, language delays.
Amongst the unvaccinated group, there were zero.
There was zero brain dysfunction, zero diabetes, zero behavioral problems,
zero learning disabilities, zero intellectual disabilities, zero ticks, and zero other psychological
disabilities. None.
It's a big difference.
Very important to study suicide at day.
This is devastating.
This paper should have rushed to publication on an emergency basis.
We are systematically making kids sick, and not just a little bit sick, very sick.
This may be the most important study there's ever been done, and it needs to be published.
He knows if he puts his name on this, his career is over.
I mean, obviously, like, really much more.
Zervos probably gonna lose this job over this.
This is an inconvenient study for the entire vaccine agenda.